[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey hello happy Thursday everybody I'm
Eric Tay that's obviously Nick margarita
school wearing some jerseys I'm trying
to rep the 49ers back when you know we
actually got to this Super Bowl and
we're I'm just gonna say this real quick
you can't spell elite quarterback
without yachties no just please just
saying no none of that
so thank you guys for tuning in we're
gonna play Madden NFL 18 today that's
why we're wearing the jerseys not just
because it's a random stream or
something we're gonna be open up packs
we're gonna do some mutt challenges and
maybe did you say gauntlet sorry gaunt
let's see which one of us can get
further in the gauntlet yeah and then
we'll probably end up playing each other
as we did last year
just so that Nick gets a chance to
actually I need that sweet sweet sweet
redemption I know you do I need so we
are we are fun fact I bought it I bought
a like a set of packs thinking like it
was gonna then let me open it but then
once I bought it we should have got it's
sure to started open them so we got an
elite at least in the first one you
doubted it because we're buying the
packs that don't necessarily guarantee
you and elites but we're gonna continue
opening packs this is our first one this
is Bryce McCain once you start we get
Marcus Wheaton he's he's pretty good
it's pretty good
Marcus Wheaton lots of names that I know
he's in Chicago now which is there's
gonna die there she's good all right so
we'll open up another one so let me make
sure I'm opening the correct pack here
it's this one oh no no no yes yes it is
that one oh okay
was it this one I guess I guess you only
get a pack I thought that your oh my bad
and then a for gold or better two silver
better alright so it does not say
there's any guarantee you're gonna get
core for play so I misunderstood that as
in like you were getting four packs from
nine hundred points and that turns out
no no no no no that's not how math works
it is very expensive
not so much anyways next pack alright
five points let's do it let's see we got
and just so you know about tooth that to
twenty two hundred points is about
twenty dollars so I don't know that guy
that's a bust silver alright go gold hey
Jones I don't know him either Quinton
Dunbar I've heard of him okay 72 gold
PJ Dawson this is a bus so far oh god
you don't have good luck Oh Sam Bradford
Sammy B that's back-to-back elites
without guaranteed elites problem what's
the problem I took Brady as my
quarterback so Bradford is gonna be
riding my bench the goat I took him as
my goat card yes I did
yeah it just so we just River knows
we're playing on ps4 Pro and I already
opened the packs from the goat Edition
Oh so that's so my team is a little bit
built already but not quiet
uh what's up max Verstappen all right
here we go yeah all right next pack
hoping for the best starting off with
the gold CJ spiller solid okay he used
to be good you know I don't know if he's
still good but he used to be good he's
in a loaded Kansas City backfield let's
go nope all right John okay come on nope
Gold's gold all right we got pretty
lucky before that Nick all right yeah
room point pack that you can buy that's
like another zero um you mind when gold
packs but nice but you can't get elites
from that right now I know nobody wants
that oh really
nobody wants gold cards we're going for
the elites elites or nothing
yeah but this is let's go for it III
think we're doing pretty like I don't
think you're gonna get one here but
we'll see hopefully I'm wrong maybe
later if in the stream if the counters
say that they're interested I will buy
out of my pocket some more because my
team is a little weak right now
it could be getting better though right
now it has mana lead come on red red red
no cold all right two out of four that's
not bad
worst case is you can always sell those
cards as well right so maybe maybe elite
to Bradford goes for like a decent
amount of
some coins and then you can spend those
coins on I can do this really quick you
a bustah player back we'll see we'll see
what we get here just for funsies let's
see we need some like hmm I'm not sure
what you're short on Lance Kendricks Wow
he's only at 71 a lot of these players
Toronto Alison they're obviously their
numbers are lower because I'd like the
tier they are well so I think from what
I understand how this works and operates
is so I have a bunch of junk Texan
players but I have JJ Watt and I want JJ
Watt to be stronger so I think for every
four players like junk Texan players I
can kind of turn them in for tokens that
allow me to upgrade some of my more
elite players which is kind of cool got
some salt I I recognized some names
there so that's good what's alright
Barry let's let's uh let's go ahead and
update are you gonna pay your rocks
let's update my roster and see what's
going on here and we'll kind of go
through and I'll show you guys what I've
I've built up into this point or Romo
right so we just generate best lineup
right now and you took Julio Jones / obj
I did it's like and I'm a trader but if
this was real like real NFL I would be
very happy with my decision because he's
hurt and got drunk old Gronk alright
alright so right now my offense kind of
man by DeSean and Julio Jones that's a
solid yeah okay your your weapons look
good your line looks kind of mediocre
the line is very mediocre but Giovanni
is pretty good Doug Martin behind them
nice got the goat though you ready for
the arguably the goat check out who's my
second back he was my first back he
must've picked up somebody rob and then
look our boy Glen Gronkowski isn't that
funny the brought the brothers the Gronk
brother is sure then ID ah let's see
anybody know : elite now you got two
elites now that we got that worked out
or Bryce McCain McCain Champ Bailey
though he's a legend
nice legend gr legend here's the biggest
problem what's that your kicker
oh wow your kick wow yeah all right
can't kick field goals got some
all right we going on it fourth down
every time we going for it look says go
for it so in order to you know purchase
some some things in the auction house we
have to play some solo challenge dealer
to get some coins so yes I was
mentioning earlier I think GD
shenanigans was saying absolutely you
can play the CPU and there are ton of
challenges and get coins from yeah right
so that's also a good way viable way to
get players and hopefully can bid on
some players like Nick needs to probably
bid on a kicker ideal here I need a
kicker and right now they're very
expensive they're extremely expensive
that's insane to me that you're you you
have no special teams basically yeah I
well the weird thing is like all these
cart packs have been opening because I I
bought a couple myself too I haven't
gotten any special teams car cats like
and there are no special teams players
in those card packs so I tried to go on
an auction house yesterday and pick up
the Giants kicker what's the guy's name
the new guy roses or whatever
I couldn't he was like twenty two
thousand coins Cameron special teams
he's saying special team is always
camped in Ultimate Team yeah I don't
know I saw some I've been watching some
people play and it seems like you can
get some pretty big run backs now I
don't know if that was just a few times
I watched but uh and I think Chuck is
saying how is growing 276 so I agree
Gold's low right but I picked him up
from one of these single-player
challenges and so now it's up to me to
get him to upgrade him by using other
cards I pay they're an elite version of
Gronk there's gotta be right here hassel
yeah their house it's like a tier of
cards so he got Nick got that as he
mentioned through the challenge so maybe
he's at like they want you to take
advantage of that upgrade system also
how wrong is this Tom Brady in a New
York Giants Jersey yeah I saw a lot of
weird stuff yesterday I think I was
watching I don't know off me
people know Erik problem right but uh
he's dreamed up some man and for us
before he's a pro player and he had like
Derek karna Niner Jersey so oh and now
look at this baby I was not reading the
challenge details
it was score touchdown in one play I
thought oh no oh no it's not okay we're
good I thought it was one point one
plays done okay
all right so right now score what was
the challenge I didn't read the
challenge I guess we just have as many
plays as it takes to get in there so
let's try to hit your crunk or Julio as
Nathan mentioned yeah the Gronk that we
discussed Oh she'll pick six bad making
those mistakes yeah I know this it's
already here in my head already
No all right so these are single player
that's right this count Gronk baby yeah
he well yeah he is he's not he's not an
elite I got him from playing just one of
these challenges camp gaming we'll do
some one-on-one towards the end of the
stream you know we'll probably have like
well at least one salty runback I can
feel it already
like a meal after that after that Nick
yeah I can feel it too from from Nick
already he's already oh you almost
through another one there I feel like
risky I should be running game looks
good though and yes some yeah some fun
facts this is the first Madden that's on
the that's on the frostbite engine from
EA which is pretty cool and I think
things look really good I've seen some
arguments about things like helmets
looking too blocky sometimes but I've
been pretty impressed by the way the
graphics have been looking I think the
frostbite engine works the best when
it's in this kind of situation whoa what
a tackle where it's in a stadium it's a
controlled environment when it's like
open-air kind of like Mass Effect I'm
not very impressed with the Frostbite
engine yeah but look at that it looks so
good also just so you guys know our own
Alex Newhouse revealed Madden NFL 18 and
gave it a 9 out of 10 and he loved it
yeah so if you guys were curious about
that or want to read his review or watch
the video review that stuff is up on
GameSpot as well as YouTube so you know
if you haven't subscribed and whatnot
you should do that so you can get
notified as to when we do reviews games
and gameplay and we appreciate it also
so you get notified that we're alive
yeah every day at 11:00 absolutely spot
live yeah Cadbury making a good point I
wish it was on the switch yes I can see
this being a pretty good I mean like I
don't know how graphics graphically it
would look but I could see that'd be
like I would want to play Madden well we
know ETA Z FIFA is on the way to the
switch
so there's there's no reason why you
know like a sports game can't tell I
watch my friend play Madden mobile he
just enjoys it he likes looking at the
routes and and things like that yeah and
so you know I could totally see madam
being a great like you know on the BART
on the bus yeah you can play the CPU
it's totally fine you know one of the
one of the modes I'm sure a lot of
people are gonna be asking about is is
the new story mode the long shot long
shot yeah that is the big edition right
that is the big edition it's a big
addition and I think it adds something
that Madden has been missing for a long
time we're not gonna go over it in this
stream just because it's very cinematic
it's a lot of dialogue and we honestly
wouldn't have the opportunity to talk to
you guys if that was the case it's a
good pass there we go nice was that yeah
yeah Sean date Sean Jackson in the New
York giant uniform yeah we also have
some gameplay of long shot up if you
you're curious about it like the first
20 or so minutes of it yellow first 20
or so minutes I know that it is spoiler
heavy it reminds me a lot of a telltale
game to be honest and it's it's a good
telltale game with a very compelling
story that if you're a football fan it's
gonna like hit home for you
like I have I'm just because I want to
know like the comparison between that
and like now you know Madden doing it
because it seems to be like that's the
trend now right like they need like the
natural progression or evolution of
these sports games you know FIFA even
has their you know their story mode now
and it's about yeah what it would be
like if you were to try to ascend into
you know the NFL or college or call yeah
then NFL right so I think it's awesome
that they have it I think it's an
experience that a lot of players will
enjoy yeah as you know it's something
different obviously and it got a hundred
coins could've got a thousand if I had
scored it on the first play I'll have to
understand I guess 800 and you get a
pack yes so this is uh
these packs don't usually entail cards
or like players oh they do
alright well sometimes it's contracts
and sometimes it's uniforms
everyone was here said launch I was
probably the most fun I've had playing
Madden since the old man in oh six mini
camps yeah I honestly I completely agree
I really do and I think this story hits
home for like and it shows it shows why
football is so important to some people
and like why it's like a part of life
like yeah like here in Texas yeah Friday
Night Lights I mean I've got like high
school football college football please
EA please bring back NCAA football I
would give anything for it but in it but
to be able to play some of these
challenges with the new what's his name
the main character I'm forgetting his
name if so many chat wants to remind me
what the main character's name is but he
plays for Texas and it's some of the
challenges you could play in a Texas
Longhorn uniform and that's awesome it's
so sick to be able to play an NC
double-a hit play a little Devon Wade
Thank You Cameron I've totally left this
pit not thinking like if this is a good
or bad spot I think it's I think we're
good yeah I think it's gonna affect some
stuff later but you know it's fine I can
always get rid of the PIP to you guys a
bit Oh what am i doing so this is
another challenge we finished the first
challenge which is just a score
touchdown this one is to rush for 20
yards Chuck Leclerc and YouTube chat
bring up a good point people is gonna be
EA's test and if that goes well I'm sure
Madden 19 whoop see ya Bob are you Chris
Berman oh and probably Madden will then
be on the swish that makes a lot of
sense you know obviously for obvious
reasons yeah looky Benny with the good
hair oh look at him and his boys Colt
cruise missile crews yakult missile crew
cruise missile okay it's cuz I'm a
master jiu ker okay oh and I heard
they've tweaked the Jukes a little bit
I'm not gonna lie
we'll see a lot of it in the gauntlet
mode like the oh there they are coke
cruising Devon Wade yeah I lay there
when it said breaking tackles is awesome
in this game I think it's so much more
responsive than it was last year
I've seen some kind of buggy glitchy
stuff though with a braking we're like
the animation of like someone holding
some
up like they're like they're like oh
like you're for some reason like your
team thinks you're gonna tackle them
yeah and then like for some reason if
they break the tackle like the rest of
your team like doesn't really pursue
yeah and that's that's a weird one so
hopefully they they're there there are
problems there are definitely problems
like sometimes when I tackle somebody
the two the two players will get caught
up with each other and okay either Lynch
down when they're trying to get blitz
through each other's chests sometimes
yeah I I showed you when I was cutting
the review for the game sometimes you'll
see these like these stars these
stutters during some of the cinematics
so not like you know I get the beginning
the game when you know Tom Brady's
running out of the the tunnel at
Foxborough and here comes the the
Falcons whatever they'll be like
specific stutters yeah I hope there's no
Falcon fans in the chat cuz man I feel
bad for you guys I was I was so happy
last year I was like oh yeah they got it
they nailed it like all they gotta do
here is just run the ball and like not
turn it over and just get a feel
chlamydia what was the challenge like is
it Arthur played front because that's
the owner like just watching Arthur
Blank on the field just like standing
there like like getting ready with a win
yeah win right and then like just like
this pause and concern Julian Edelman
makes this like ridiculous catch in like
traffic with three people you think it's
gonna get picked batted down anything he
just finds a way to like keep it alive
and it's like Tyree esque but not not
necessarily the same because Tyree we're
going deep Tyrese catch was crazy I
don't think so
yeah user catch user catch I don't know
that that's she's not having the Julio
now that was oh maybe because it was
Julio Julio never doubt the goat says
cadbury that's true I'd further kind of
uh just showed that he is probably the
goats
I saw a hilarious I mean a dank meme and
it was the Eclipse and as the moon was
getting covered up it was the score in
the third quarter and as the moon came
back it was the final score the was it
would they lose twenty eight thirty to
twenty thirty five whatever it was yeah
Oh SN Gerber baby looking teeth that's a
long username lol I'm a
conspan rip yeah man I'm sorry I'm sorry
you guys
I don't know and the funny thing funny /
scary thing for me is Kyle Shanahan is
now the Niners coach and I like it was
like you should feel good you feel like
I feel good I feel good but and in his
play calling was like masterful through
that game until that one drive Julio
makes that ridiculous catch on the
sidelines which will be like H will be
the number one thing forgotten in that
game was one of the best catches I've
ever seen it's gonna be totally easy to
tap tough sideline cash I'm like oh they
are primed here to just run it a couple
times
kick that feel to yourself possession
and then he takes a takes like a 15-yard
sack exactly that's like what what are
you doing man like yes Kyle Shanahan
called a throwing play but no QB in that
situation takes a 15-yard sack it's just
like what are you thinking dude yeah
it's uh sorry sorry I didn't want a half
you relive that OSN but yeah I just want
to go through that with you that thought
process that we're having like everyone
that's like probably watching I mean
it's kind of wild in the past like it's
been what fun in the past five Super
Bowls as everything has been very like
questionable decisions like the run with
the run and throw with what's-his-name
with uh with the Seahawks are you
kidding oh yeah yeah where he thought he
throws to like Dougie Baldwin or
whatever yeah and gets picked by Malcom
Butler great pick by Butler
obviously great read but you don't go to
your horse you don't go to Marshawn you
know they're marshal one with like
especially because like there was like a
good like forty to fifty seconds left I
feel like and it's like they had a
couple downs that they could have milt
easily even if he didn't you know punch
it in the first time it's like man like
what happened I don't it's fine it's
fine it's if you think about that if you
think about that if they had ran the
ball if both in both those situations
the coaches had chose to run the ball
Brady would have on you soon Brady would
have two less Super Bowls to last Super
Bowls he would have lost to to the
John's
Eli lead quarterback and then once of
the Seahawks one to the Falcons that's
for Super Bowl losses would he be the
goat if he had four Super Bowl worst of
all my boy Tom Manzo is in the comments
what's up Tom I just want to say this
okay
the year the Niners lost to the Giants
where you ultimately won the Super Bowl
yeah was the year the Niners should have
won the Super Bowl because that was the
year the Patriots were awful and somehow
got to the Super Bowl anyways but any
anyone knows that that that NFC
championship was essentially the Super
Bowl and you know what Thank You Kyle
Williams for fumbling twice thank you so
much I love you Kyle Williams didn't
even need offense that year we just had
to play smarter defense was so good it
must be really tough being the Niners
and watching
Kaepernick throw - Crabtree three times
and whatever we didn't run there either
I okay I'm done you know and it's funny
beats but I'm doing a running challenge
I have to run the ball eight times or
score a running touchdown also
definitely big shout out my high school
boys are in the comments what's up guys
this is the only thing they would tune
into because it's football hey Tom he's
going down I know I am played man I
personally haven't played Madden NFL 18
but I'm find a way
I might not play the Niners though I
think I have to but like after this
challenge that's getting to the gauntlet
mode we'll do a little head-to-head
gauntlet we'll see who can get further
in the gauntlet and do you think I'm
gonna suck and that and that'll give you
a little warm-up that little warm-up and
then we're going straight into
head-to-head cadbury that's fair they
were not awful is what he says he or she
says they were just mediocre but it
looked awful compared to their greatness
they they were not they they shouldn't
have gone to the Superbowl one and two
I'm pretty sure the NFC was better that
year like that was a year where like
they didn't have a lot of like studs on
the roster they just you know that New
England is New England Bill Belichick is
a genius and they got there but let's be
honest here I feel that either NFC team
that won that game should have
ultimately won that Super Bowl that year
that year specifically against New
England that year okay that year that's
that's that's my only thing that's it
I agree but yeah my friends are
my friend tom was in the comments here
he's a big big jet fan oh I'm so sorry
he's a Brady lover so let me ask you if
you're a jet fan are you allowed to be a
Brady fan that's really awkward that's
for sure
that's what we say Henry's in the
comments big blue let's go big blue I
got it I got it I gotta say though you
know Bay Area kid Tom Brady you know
Sarah High School seventh round
I wish the Niners found a way but I
think even if the Niners found a way to
pick them it wouldn't matter D wouldn't
have had as much success shout-out to
the Friends of Nick swamp Goblin
margarita says uh Gucci right it is I
think I'm good I'm gonna run I'm
probably gonna lose the ball here but
the challenge yeah well I needed a rush
eight times it's the eighth time rushing
oh my god yeah
big guy yeah alright there we go got it
big Benny Benny with the good what do
you think about guys getting hurt so far
I'm worried that low blow on obj they're
saying that he might not start Game one
I said it to my boys I was saying it now
I think it was a cheap shot but we had
this we had this discussion the other
day we had this discussion that now that
you have to go low to prevent
helmet-to-helmet contact that it causes
these kind of problems so like yep I
look oh like from what I've read Oh BJ
was not upset about the hit his
teammates were for obvious reasons I'm
stunned maybe he turned a new leaf and
he's trying to be less upset about
things but I would be upset if I were
him I mean if you watch it though right
like I didn't see it as being dirty he
was he was like a little bit above the
ground right and and the corner safety
is gonna make sure that he doesn't land
right so you're going for the legs now
did he purposely aim for his knee that's
one thing or another right his knee
slash like lower lower leg yeah right
but but that is what that will say
that's what the rule set once right they
don't want that home at the home it they
don't want the concussions so we got to
go for legs because if you go for his
waist
maybe he breaks that tackle well maybe
and then maybe breaks a
a rib if he gets hit hard enough it's
all--it's old all these rules man too
many rules well no the only rule I care
about is a celebration rule how is it
updated we should look that up right now
I'm figured out I want to know
definitively how has it updated but also
talking about injuries don't we have
Brandon Marshall maybe he's hurt too
like with a shoulder yeah here shove
Marshall has a shoulder I agree with the
harbor OSN Gerber baby that obj is gonna
have an injury-riddled year worse though
he's bear well I think it will get out
of the comet I feel like I feel like it
was more like me than ankle but they're
just like saying it's ankle and it's
concerning he did jog about like after
the game though oh this is my boy though
this right here is my shouldn't my
fantasy guy I should have let you play
on is is my guy I mean I don't know if
he can sustain a full year because he's
rarely ever done that because last year
he had the suspension in the year before
he had like minor you know I'm telling
you here for names or even with the
suspension he was a unbelievable pickin
fantasy top top three and fantasy like
yeah here's here's where I got screwed
though last year so I took levee on in
the like second on the snake coming back
cuz like I knew that if I didn't take
him and I wanted him that he wouldn't be
back around right right but here's my
here's my friend taking DeAngelo
Williams in the fifth round of a 12 team
fantasy draft and I'm like dude so he
screwed me one and two I'm like you
realize you're only gonna have D'Angelo
for like four games right and that's it
cuz like once levian comes back he's
gonna be the workhorse and he's like
unless he gets hurt right he's not like
what kind of fifth round value is that
come on oh I hate this one Oh oops you
ride saying I'll trade levy on for a
budget RB that stays healthy you're
crazy dude you're out of your mind
he's arguably the second or first best
running back in fantasy depending on how
David Johnson does but ooh here's a
question if you're if you're playing
fantasy also by the way we're playing
the gauntlet
now so you have lives and basically you
have to complete the challenges and if
you complete them then you move on to
the next level so right now I'm on level
5 I've slide my lives left because I
lost one I will see how far I can go and
I'll pass the controller every day here
and I don't see how far he can go in
otherwise we'll do a little best of like
best of 5 or something like that because
it usually takes really short to play
unless you're really good you know all
right so now this one I gotta run
through the box Danna
what I was saying is like if you're
playing fantasy this year do you take ap
with the Saints
yes but depends on what round obviously
how early do you take him I think he's I
think from some of the mocks and some
have looked at and protected I think
he's like he's like a round a fifth ish
around that fifth round area because I
mean ultimately engrams still there
right so they're still yeah there's
still gonna be some sharing but it's
still a p1 and I think like the fun fact
is like the Saints actually run a lot in
the in the red zone so he's probably
primed for maybe ten touchdowns this
year eight to ten okay is my guy
Oh Cameron saying third round maybe for
ap I don't know Cadbury we will play
towards the end of the stream probably
in another like 15 or so minutes after
the gauntlet here Jets Super Bowl champ
20 25 Tommy man so you're out of your
mind
I you guys need to make some better
draft picks and then we'll see where
that goes also man look into the future
you're crazy I can't look that far into
the future
nf 495 diss gameplay feel any different
from last year Nick what was the
question again sorry does the gameplay
feel any different than last year uh
maybe breaking tech maybe breaking
tackles feels a little bit better but
other than that it's very similar to
last year it feels good I think the
biggest improvement is probably probably
just just breaking tackles yeah any more
options but they did that last year so
hurt the safeties are a little bit
better only dead smoked DeMarco what was
that a fail what was this supposed to do
there you have two chances left
make all permanent serve go full out
with Jay Z I just
I wrapped him I here we go conservative
tackle that's lame oh here's a good one
for you Nick as a giant says Chris
Furtado from the YouTube chat and you
guys are Giants fans right he is I am
I'm a Niners fan so can we agree that
Julian Edelman catch in 51 was better
than David Tyree absolutely not I don't
think so go Tyrese I think I think
Edelman's was pretty insane yeah I agree
he still he was able to find a way to
like manage to juggle yes that catch
between like three defenders great catch
this is good Jones and super Tyree
somehow catches it holds on to it on his
helmet while he's being dragged down
like I don't know I think that was more
of a play but that's that's me I want
I'm curious what the chat things to chat
what do you guys think do you think
Edelman's cash in 51 is greater or more
special than damn dumb Tyrese in which
Super Bowl entitled Tyrese was
impressive because oh are you actually
just talking I'm saying as a football
fan Tyrese it number once yeah I agree
with Doc here it's a it's a bigger
situation number two he didn't even play
that much he's not a starter Tyree was
like a special teams bench guy and he
comes out and he does that mm-hmm like
that's great oh that was close
Oh Jimmy face the Browns are going to
win the Super Bowl this year I don't
know about that Jimmy face if you're a
Browns fan
what do you how do you what's your
feeling and I guess for the rest of chat
what's your guys it's feeling on a
Kaiser being promoted to number one so
that means there's there's trade
speculation here and Rock the lobster
Brock lobster you guys are crazy that
whole oh my god Edelman over everyone
else get out of here there's a tire up
in there that whole situation what am I
doing here making aggressive tackle
there we go
be aggressive that was a hit stick
alright 16 points I don't know what I'm
doing guys I'm gonna try my best man
what are the buttons the buttons what
welcome to the gauntlet is this the same
as where you started at it is so you
have six lives you're a level zero it'll
tell you exactly what to do
on the bottom it'll like remind you
about things so this is you're gonna be
on the blocker you're gonna match X and
try to sack Marie right yeah I think
yeah yeah God his legs
God his legs all right easy smash run
the smash Pass concept complete that
pass yeah also like catching the ball in
the helm is so unrealistic that it's
smashed it oh you know I am gonna sleep
on Kaiser
I'm already sleeping on I think he's
gonna be a total bust looks good oh it's
ten go through to the zero receiver oh
yeah a little soft seat bent big band
with a little will touch man he's
getting meat balls here these are the
easiest challenges for six seconds and
avoid okay come on over line you can do
it online you can do it oh oh yeah baby
closing up break it up
oh yeah look at that pocket alright here
we go this one's nice this one is
difficult you have to stay inside the
boxes oh it's like some Sonic [ __ ] right
here yeah I would go that way I
shouldn't be telling this but I would
[Music]
all right all right all right yes yes
that was that was real sensitive
come on levy on blossom all right all
right here we go this is a boss level no
wonder and no it's not no it's not
did it really since when is this a boss
level oh man II didn't I just I just had
to relax one I was going too fast
there's no tacklers here there's no oh I
only have one second left yeah you only
in one second oh I thought I could take
my time okay what all right Big Ben run
the flood to pass concept you pass
anyone all right looks good it's going
to levy on my boy okay okay oh where
baby oh eight beat he's wide open
hmm give him that booty shake all right
make the tackle or force him out of
bounds I had uh I had someone the other
day tell me that all we missed them yeah
I had somebody tell me the other day
that the Giants their turbo button there
is what sir it's the right trigger right
trigger okay I had somebody tell me the
other day well this is awkward angle
that the Giants had like the eighth
worst roster in the league the Giants
yeah really
whoever said that if you're listening
and you're watching I don't know where
you came up with that why is the wind
that's a great phrase II what is this oh
yeah it's it's just gauntly you get it's
a skill challenge Oh God
crossbar Daniel oh baby oh oh baby boy
oh I do it just for that oh my gosh
sorry sorry Chad all right
Oh back to oh you gotta do it again do
it again here we go here we go it's like
this is like basketball there's so much
rumbling you guys we know that's perfect
no it's going that way oh no Bend It
Like Beckham Bosworth that's no way it
was there dude he's got the bend all
right bullet plows have a hold down the
receiver but no problem
where's a B where's my boy a B I should
be okay well that's it a B all day
no one can guard him Oh Annie stayed up
what a stud all right oh I love this
this is a boss OS oh this is a boss yes
incoming boss so you have doing spots
avoid them you have to avoid the hot
spots and score and score TD with all
these you have to do this yeah of course
but no not not my run not have to do it
oh my god
all right let's go I'll play get up
leave your baby stay out of there all
your blockers oh he's gone see yeah we
done baby we got levian old idea they're
rude oh that was too easy too easy for
him gauntlet that's why we have to plays
your life challenge but I was saying is
uh oh s n Gerber that's a great comma is
he saying that David Tyree had as many
receptions in his career as most had in
a single hole stay up stay up
Wow this is difficult like what 20-yard
blockers in do [ __ ] oh I think it was an
extra life challenge blew it yeah that's
fine
press or tap presser tap Oh gross of
tackle presser time oh my god just press
don't hold Oh make it rain Dan this
looks hard have the Puntland in the hot
zone I've never done this one he can't
kick to the big hot zone oh okay we he
can you just have to hope it bounces in
Oh
the speaker spot I mean you got a gauge
here okay okay all right okay well soft
touch oh no am i rolling though it's
like top top shot goal me yeah it is
top top golf tight oh what's that place
called is it top call
it's a tough call someone someone a chat
figure this yeah actually my boys are
still in there our buddy James who's
getting married congratulations James
he lives near top golf it's top golf and
selfie talk talk talk Golf he lives near
one he big top golf guy I actually think
the wedding reception when we first get
there is that top golf hell yeah [ __ ]
pumped
let's go you gotta go deep go deep yeah
T Golf Towel kind of straight oh it's a
rollin rollin rollin yeah
it's gonna ruin Oh didn't even need it
didn't even need it
all right medium passing use L to lead
the past downfield and complete the two
lives left
level 12 I only got to level 16 does
that work
I don't know yeah let's go it worked
let's go medium power run the power
concept and get it first all right okay
check which side Oh too fast
he's too fast Oh still up what a stud
talk all thanks James
Oh boss running back gauntlet okay you
this one sucks all right here we go all
right you're gonna get around him get
around here but they can't catch you
when you're trying to get away from
these guys oh boy oh boy
Oh dead murdered last life you have to
finish this okay all right okay
Oh Oh baby Dada Dada Dada Dada
damn this is gonna be close that's being
talked ed Oh what are we doing here stay
in the hot spot for three seconds throw
the ball without taking a sack where are
my guys though can i yeah there you go
know what you hold them treat her like a
look around there you go baby oh god
he's gone the deep brown Deus is running
the in okay here we go two three three
squared
yes oh you said they get the ball oh
yeah we tied baby all right
first third and five make a first down
easy easy it's over here how does this
oh no he's creeping that Safety's
creepin kind let's see
come on safety oh yes game tied ball
game let's go baby hackle all right
motor lucky dude I tied you on my first
try and let me tell you something this
is gone
NFL score is zero to zero let's go dude
that is man that was my first time ever
playing the gauntlet okay so the fact
that I tied him
what's up Blake curry hello I'm the high
fire bucket come the excuses I knew they
were coming
I lose he's never gonna let me live it
down today what excuse I'm just telling
the chat that was the first time I've
ever done gauntlet and I tied Nick now I
don't know how many hours played in a
cashew not like he's probably got like
eight to ten get four games yeah the
hours played in Madden 87 six six six
six more than I have we'll settle this
in our heads up match it's fine we
should just play heads up right now oh
you wanted to play heads up we should
just play heads up so we can get like to
two games in and you want me to finish
this your owners play heads up I think
we should just well why cuz you get
coins no no let's just let's just go
let's just go let's let's play heads up
it's not that's what the chat wanted on
its time all right chat put your ones in
the chat if you think Nick New York
Giants and margarita is gonna win it's
time to go or put your twos in chat if
you think Eric 49ers tay is gonna win
all right
granted experience here six hours i have
now 10 minutes under my belt in the
gauntlet so I want to at least give the
chat a fair representation of what
you're potentially betting on because
chances are you should probably go with
him however I will say for those that
don't know we did this stream last year
for an F Madden NFL so I won't lie I
lost on every game I lost every game I
probably threw about 20 picks I was I
was under duress
I was pressured it was also my second
stream here at GameSpot I am a stream
veteran now I will not allow this to
happen
no no excuses I lost I lost fans here's
a question I like the threes with a
random threes the threes is neutral
three freezing we both look Nick and
chat whenever my what number am I or one
I'm thinking do we have to play the same
team and or are we trying to square
overalls or do we not care that is a
stupid I just want to understand the
stipulation why don't we do all I'll
play is the let's play the first game
Giants Niners just because we have two
all right
and then because the Niners are
obviously worse than the Giants the next
game you can be a better team than me
all right within within whatever that
you're the mate ish overall eight ish
over okay all right okay all right what
all right Kyle please we're playing an
all-pro all-pro I'm I'm gonna wear the
throwback there's enhanced edit my
uniform or these are nature's color
brushes are tight Oh Nike Nike away
Jersey where's my dude there I not have
to rush oh oh let's go okay oh wait what
wait hold on why is it why is it not
staying why there you go
why is it not saying what go go back now
stop hey yeah mmm patience patience you
know I'm getting a lot of votes I
appreciate that
wow there's a lot of y-you I couple ones
yeah
I'm some twos and threes seen a lot of
fuzzy majority threes which don't count
from where you must mean they don't care
or they're not invested okay how do you
want to do this you want to manage the
clock here a little bit or do we just
play no we're all right so this is I'm
pretty sure Newhouse told me this is a
brand new mode it's called arcade mode
and basically over-the-top action filled
spectacular place if you go deep
there is like a 75% chance that your
receivers in catch it but there's also a
lot of high chance of interceptions -
okay so limited penalties lots of
scoring it's gonna be some let's think
about this guy's I'm gonna lower I'm
gonna lower the quarters down to four
minutes so we can play more Oh BJ
Brandon Marshall Shepherd versus my
receiving core which is chef Sarah
Carson marques Goodwin and Jeremy Kerley
did Garcon just retire who just retired
and Quan bolt older dude
Stud for the Niners and the rape I just
saw her on my phone last night
does anyone remember that devastating
hit he took where he still caught the
ball when he's on Arizona he got on the
cake between two people and basically
got concussed he had to have his jaw
shut because of that damn
it's a crazy hit Cameron says GameSpot's
do even team get out here that's boring
or fine we're fine come on I'm not
afraid that's more of a reason it's
gonna feel good when these 76 rating
Niners gets it done with Carlos Hyde who
doesn't look good in pre-season by the
way also who is excited for the Raiders
to go to Las Vegas I am I feel bad for
all the Oakland fans it's like it's like
the Warriors going to SF like I'm torn
on that too I feel like I rather good
good for business it's good for business
this guy this corporate business I'm a
big business guy I've been watching a
lot of ballers on HBO and it's all about
what kind of bull crap we need to get
rid of this PIPP dude rolled in got
destroyed I'm letting these ranking City
Beauty thank you oh look at MetLife oh
the most beautiful stadium in the whole
world Giants guy master of NBA 2k we are
not doing any giveaways from that in NFL
18 unfortunately sorry oh
Cadbury though oh good one oh this is a
good weather or my Greg oh we're gonna
fall down a hole and never come out
let's go empty MacGregor I hate
Mayweather I can't wait Saturday's gonna
be the best night of my life
I can't wait yeah that's right Corrine
Tommy tell them boo the Raiders they
should stay in Oakland Oh Jeremy Kerley
the curling man yo curly man baby's
gonna may weather is going down here's
here's official prediction you heard it
here first
Mayweather will be knocked out knocked
out within three rounds or Mayweather
will win by decision and they will go
the distance which I I would say but did
you know did you know that 95%
according to ESPN last night 95% will
you bring it out
you're crazy dog come on curly 95% of
the Vegas bets that have been made are
on McGregor but it makes sense because
the odds yeah BC you'd have to bet $250
in order to make a hundred dollars
behind Hoyer a boy Brian Hoyer can i Wow
bet he didn't even have a highlight reel
the background better in here man yeah
Oh another great question is Cutler on
the Dolphins roster in this yes he is
yes he is he's it's updated already he
is on there that is correct City they're
getting paid to win or lose they don't
really care it's a payday man that's why
I like I don't know I feel like we did
you hear him go ahead eight ounce gloves
and that he's gonna knock him out in
like two rounds who Mayweather McGregor
McGregor said that I'm telling you I
read McGregor
so I've been now this conversation my
buddy Matt from back home there's
there's been this like flip-flopping
where it was his support and he saw the
Tom Brady here little o matic connection
Brady has been texting Mayweather all
week giving him encouragement telling
him he could do this tell him he's got
this and all this grass of all time and
he's the greatest of all time but then
Mayweather came out today and said for
all the [ __ ] talking then that
Mayweather has been giving McGregor he
better be ready to take it essentially
saying like you better be ready I'm
coming for you in the ring so look if I
can weigh him he's distracted chat first
down to my man Pierre I'm fired up I
can't wait for this fight yeah Garza
wells fight you're not even worried
about this game that you're about to
lose I am extremely worried about this
game this is that first day I like my
beloved Carolina Tarheels
this is the Redemption tour get to uh
the curly man so open I'm playing so
deep come on you don't know you don't
know about these these Niners that are
gonna hopefully tank this year and then
get Kurt cousins
Kurt cousins he just franchised them
didn't he yeah franchise is fine dude
he's gonna that they design it to an
extent yes we are because weird like we
were like one of the people that was
like oh maybe we'll trade this is does
he still want to come
San Francisco wants to play with Kyle
Shanahan baby Zach you Oh
let's go Carlos you take five yards baby
you got to mix up your game I will never
forget never forget it was like my first
week when I was working at ESPN back in
the day and I was playing a little
fantasy football one of those like
FanDuel like one night games and I took
a pee over Carlos Hyde Carlos Hyde went
off and I lost like $20 what a terrible
snap I was like Kilgore upset last yard
cause of that I wonder I wonder if these
updates wonder if they changed my lineup
no cuz Oh BJ still in the game right I
think I'm good where's Olivier Olivier
burnin horse in it yeah told you I was
forcing it man
J kids they call him the Jackrabbit
you're Norris Jenkins let's go I knew I
shouldn't I knew it - I knew it was a
bad I need was a bad throw
I try to gun it in there it's okay oh
right back to their good some concepts I
am legitimately
when I'm passing with you I am as
nervous as I am actually throwing a real
pass goob says he hates Rudy for Nick
but I switched guys where's Oh BJ oh
yeah whoa get home baby where is my old
line Oh kidding me well stunt I don't
even know how to switch my my characters
was that a user tackler
no I didn't I don't know how to switch
my dear how do I switch to switch deep
man
how do I switch to demon Oh B and then
you like push it towards man I get my
controls McClement Thomas right here
Salma Thomas
oh it's Alma targets coming there we go
that's all right that's all right nice
born have you can have your
little ten-yard I needed to get those
yards back and get those yards back man
I am the hype over Shanahan is that he
revolutionized the Falcons season last
year was a big reason why Matt Ryan won
MVP and they got to the Super Bowl I
agree yeah force Buckner UI looks so
good
in the white jersey though that's our
new tight end first rounder let's go lip
I lit up Eli there I lit him up
it's our first rounder baby oh shoot the
quarters already over oh my bad maybe I
should leave say fine we'll play another
game
let him up anybody in chat does anyone
remember where Ingram came from what
school he went to was it seems in
Alabama I know it's an SEC team much
don't know who I don't know then it
might have been Mississippi State I'm
not sure though man you are bringing the
play let's go Rueben foster bringing the
pressure he was Bama theama
I told you right I said Alabama right I
had to throw that Alabama's right there
baby Rueben foster I had to throw I was
under extreme
how are you rushing me so hard I don't
know man are you see I'm not blitzing
him I have a pressure every year
overthrow sucks what can I say my whole
line does sigh say I needed that to be
somebody get the ball back at the half
if I had at least get on some points
there can I say what can I say I'm
hoping he's the net we have Patrick
Willis really really hoping he's the
next coming oh why did I spin there
there we go that's wrong button
Oh miss oh yeah I agree I don't think
he's Bama I know as an SEC team but I
don't remember who was an au j Howard
Bama I don't oh joy Howard's another one
of those like stud tight ends that came
out this year I think maybe he was
Alabama and not who we think I think
it's Ole Miss who Jay was out of Bama
yeah thanks James
who was it Mitchell chewinsky no he was
too who's won that
it was a Charlaine the show no no he
traded they traded oh oh
leaving guy Oh miles gears miles Garrett
thank you
fudge I don't remember my play it feels
like it's been a while since the draft
get there let's go sell a what is that
let's go first down
Pam stop throwing picks I know we got it
we got to stop throwing picks I agree we
did turn arcade mode which is like a
Pixar like but also deep passes are
turned the eff up - we gotta go deep I
shouldn't said that to you because now
you're gonna get deep days legend are
there a lot of changes since Madden 17
there are a fair amount of changes
number one of which which is brand new
is the long shot
story mode reminds me of telltale game
with a little bit of Madden football
challenges you know it's all good that
your labor Gangi all that matters is
legit okay here we go I need to bring
the pressure he's open let's go mance
McDonald I wish we traded him nobody
wanted him though ah I miss when we
actually had a tight end that was decent
aka Vernon Davis but we looking good I'm
having I'm having a good old time here
trying to March trying to March here
bring the heat no I don't bring the heat
let's go let's go all right Kyle
Shanahan offense here come on hold him -
I feel Globox baby where's my box hold
them to a field go please please two
minutes
two-minute warning we gucci we gucci you
don't see that bad no I'm just also
speaking of bad kickers can you believe
they cut Aguayo
needs a backer though number one yam cop
to the fact that first round a kicker no
a second round win the first round I
thought you a second round otherwise is
he sticking around
maybe he's first round maybe that's why
it's even worse but I thought was second
round first round second round doesn't
matter if your kicker and you're that
early of a pick and you get cut you
should be ashamed of yourself oh I meant
to throat r1 oh he's out I got it press
the rock no he caught it okay no I did
but now God I through I was pressing the
wrong button he was open for days he was
no Jude Nick he was he was open I just
pressed our two instead of our one yeah
all right with 37 do you guys ever play
NHL I haven't played that much Cadbury I
have sharks are one team we're only
getting worse
Marlo going to the Leafs is a pain
painful for me here's a hockey question
for you I'm not really a big hockey guy
can i really big hockey guy but with the
the expansion draft did that like did
that screw you Oh Oh Eli
Apple Thank You challenge I'm a
challenge that I don't like you can
write you can't the two minutes poaching
two minutes of a half play you can't
yeah two minutes Ritchie Ritchie says
Ritchie says you guys think I'm about to
leave whatever Pierre oh yes yes so
stupid you what a great route to what a
great play great route alright come on
baby when I get unlucky come on baby
that's um
all right minute 48 oh my god with the
pressure
how are you always getting birthday
round pick Solomon Thomas is coming to
get you golly Ingram looks a little jank
his face I'm not gonna lie to rookie
they probably don't bring them in
yeah but he's like a good looking dude
you look a little Jack here Earl
Mitchell are we gonna saw him in Thomas
here we're gonna saw him in
oh yes yes Marshall Brandon my boy great
play
all right minute fourteen I'm not ready
I'm not ready to start rushing yet I
will though after this that's assault
play here we go oh no no no no he's out
no way
I know it's obj but he ate no no I just
lay I just do it in ten I just threw it
to their own person to thank God look at
the tattoos also update Madden update
tattoos a lot of people will we're
excited about that OBJ's twos look dank
that was a ghost acacho by obj you gotta
say that was sick Hitler sure alright 56
seconds we need to get some points here
boys we need some bottom bubble oh yeah
swag on him swag swag on goop says get
it together Nikki let him get in your
head he is in my head he's in my head
from last year I actually though I know
this isn't gonna be a popular thing to
say I feel good right now feel good
last year was a nightmare
Eli I got that stick them stick them bro
home one more time no way I send it send
the heat burned him Oh sterling Shep
what's diving catch
sterling Shepard that's my boy oh my god
good that helmet was good
oh [ __ ] clock still running I'm gonna
call timeout
skipping this you got time to wait for
that no we got time for none of us
should stay to cover to just now we I
think we stayed in covered - we were
just got stopped there what do I do here
no I'll feel good I'm gonna be sick you
guys come on no air greet let's go Eric
Reid what's happening again man hands
are head coach I think I should just
kneel it out it's happening again
oh god I don't think you can kneel it
out cuz that would be safety you're on
the two yard line
and I'm bringing the heat that I'm
throwing a quick class quick pass here
[Music]
okay that's alright come on Vance I
gonna let a deal I'm and stop you
I feel genuinely sick to my stomach a
shindig auntie I just went how I
should've ran out and just got out of
bounds save the clock I timeout left
I did throw in a double coverage I know
that I know
Cameron remind him I'm not him what he
didn't know except for the good thing
about last year was y'all I threw it oh
my god
Oliver safety safety punt what yes
safety oh my dude I got rid of it did he
did he do that preseason thing were you
like yes yes yes
let's go 18 seconds still enough to
throw in deep lair Ritchie Ritchie says
I'm out I've had enough what you don't
like my safety
these kids these days oh [ __ ] come on
never good enough all right are you guys
playing on a touchdown any time soon
yeah I know right
defense is two good defense wins
championships it's calm and we're just
gonna let's go baby let's go let's just
back it up back it up
all right time out time out time with
town-o town-o town-o town-o it man we
play cover three there it's here how the
hell did you get that far I have to get
kick feel go from here all right why
would you spin on him there okay a
column Oh what are you doing more time
that's bad even if he caught it he would
have got laid out there Lee Howie you go
get the ball back you're outside he
thought about it though that pisses me
off so let's go pinyon oh shoot it kind
of went a little bit to the left it
would be fine to kick off Jaworski I'm
not taking this out you wouldn't kneel
Dwayne Harris you're not gonna run Nate
Dwayne Harris out come on man that's
always good for special some kind on the
ball oh okay now I can play
conservatively because I got some time
this guy whatever that means
what happened to our pressure let's go
alright you know what we need to also
get perkins involved Oh
let's go shut that tackle or you can get
it wide open
i'ma get it that's how you shed a tackle
to make a tackle damn it damn that was
awesome great job
zoom all right
oh that's I was that not a fumble how is
mine a fumble and how is that not a
bumble he literally fell and then lost
the ball I hate to say this but I agree
I agree that probably should have been
Thomas
Ola user tassel op one person so I got
him swag on I have no time to get the
ball off won't you are you punting yeah
I have to I'm like what 19 yards back oh
my god what a joke of a no line you know
what start agree with people got all the
offensive weapons we need but we don't
have anybody okay my god stiff up oh
let's go oh my god go on forth or go huh
no right cavalry no balls a 19-yard well
not even unlike the 12 yards tell him
he's got no balls 19 years ago
get out of here NFC East is gonna be lit
this year says mgs legacy I think either
my Eagles or your Giants will win gonna
agree to disagree
don't forget about Dallas I guess they
got they got Al Sean I just don't see I
know you're probably an eagle fan I just
you see that route you're not you're
gonna I didn't see how to say you're
gonna have to show me something special
got him thank God sin says her sin e
says I heard the Giants only have one
good receiver this year and they're
injured is that true not true
we have obj Brandon Marshall sterling
Shepherd and the new guy Ingram don't
members first name my bad for dogs his
path to win the Superbowl if I were to
go to Vegas right now and put some money
down I would agree I hate that I have to
agree with you parade route baby hold on
to it murder him murder of jinora duty
smoked your linebacker whoever that was
a little tight and fade
- Vance yeah I'm with roadblock I
honestly even with Ezekiel Elliott
suspension I still think the couple is
there gonna be play all like Dax gonna
have a not-so-great year though why I
don't know where you can come up with
that sophomore slump I I think he's fine
to come in in a Tony Romo system I do
what he did he wasn't even a rookie he
didn't even belong in the field if it
wasn't for Tony getting hurt he wouldn't
mean played Tony got hurt in pre-season
no mmm I think so oh my god come on
let's go they can't they can't stop you
ban it's not in this game isn't most of
the Cowboys team suspended well lucky
Whitehead was suspended and then you
pull on there and then they let go lucky
Whitehead right Evan Engram thank you
Thank You old mess oh break that tackle
I don't know if I have any cords that's
fine just a little cord load doesn't
mean that it's gonna die 12/5 oh we good
don't worry are we gonna play another
game after might we might have to well
we'll see we'll see we'll see what
happens looking Laura we can speed up
the game 36 seconds left in the third
oh my god over oh what a catch should
have lofted it over his back back on the
receiver opted it over back on the
receivers wrap picked it off
that's almost a mistake Brian horik guns
it in there with his big arm speed up
the play Carlos nobody there
yeah there's your touchdown for to go
for to go for two here
I'm watching you did you though there's
a fake and oh no all right here we go
nailed it perfect right down the middle
Robbie Gould Betty seven to one girl
four minutes I should hate Robbie Gould
though cuz he missed that field goal
against the Niner well it's actually
funny because he missed that field goal
against the Niners we score in overtime
and basically dropped a draft pick down
but then they decide to give us for
Mitchell true Biscay an extra pick so I
guess it ended up being in in our favor
so Mitchell Travis Keys the UNC guard at
UNC I over to a huge UNC basketball fan
I do not watch UNC football and I've
heard all good things about this
Mitchell kid but I just see like good in
his a game one I didn't watch that game
too but his game one he was pretty
accurate I think he had like at least
one if not two touchdowns yeah I just I
haven't like done any research on them
so Nick is crumbling dot him up who said
that
dot him up no crumbly Oh Mike let's go
Witherspoon I don't know who that is
it's happening again this is literally
how it went down last year unbelievable
gotta milk the clock I think Ruben
Foster is gonna be a bullion so um GS
legacy I'm hoping we found our next
coming of oh [ __ ]
Oh give them the spin give them the spin
again that's being out of bounds sorry
my Cameron says the choke continues Nick
is having PTSD yes I should have scored
there I think I'm not gonna score
because I Karma's gonna come back around
for I am having extreme PTSD I try to
swag on I'm too hard there and I god oh
my god how is he breaking all these
tackles I think I'm not gonna score now
because I did that double spin that
ended up me going out of it you're gonna
score
you'll find a way you'll find a way to
put it right my face feeling bad
got it oh my god spun out at the teat a
you so dirty Carlos alright we don't get
punished guys didn't get punished yet we
didn't get punished we just kick the p80
nothing fancy here up to possession got
to keep it simple on d3 13 so only the
score TV almost blogs make sure to just
pick the Falcons because I feel you
Cadbury oh I see you in the chat oh
that's horrible
how bad is that of your Falcon fan
that's like the ultimate insult take a
knee take a knee
oh my god why are you coming out oh okay
I thought you survived two hits we're
just gonna play some pretty bass real
bass D here almost safe I'm afraid to
throw the ball I am afraid to throw the
ball oh I try to use her why did I do
that
just let the AI play the game Erik don't
try to don't try to get fancy I thought
I could cover Marshall there when I play
alone
I always monitor all my receivers oh
let's go let's go Robin
how do i how do i how do i taught you
all the time you how do i do let's go
let's go
that's why you let the AI take over
Russia Robinson who's getting
straight-up burnt in pre-season comes
out with a pick six oh I hate this I'm
gonna have to wait a whole nother year
no you got another game after this I'm
gonna have to wait a whole nother year
for this I'm never streaming this we
onside kick up guys if I could come for
fun man the events have been solid
I hate my job gold strong K need
everything Jase 81 he's game was really
good yeah it does look really good
I agree Reuben Fosters coming on the
hunt okay Eli Harold
oh he sheds it get off me get off me oh
there's too many though so I'm gonna
call the police
I witnessed a murder you wanted your
touchdowns we gettin um we gettin em
chat are we going back to some safe some
safe three-man rush you know just
bringing our L to R to X R that earth I
think it's zero or circle okay
oh I would for the user
this doesn't make it any better
this makes it no better dang it chat I
tried to I tried to something to try to
do something I shouldn't have this makes
it absolutely no bad bad my bad I
shouldn't have done that I I thought I
could bring the safety over and pick it
and boy was I wrong
this makes it absolutely perfect this is
like fantasy uh Oh Gino Smith Oh pick
that and take that to the haha Gino hold
it and throw it also how f mean Gino my
backup
that's roses well yeah I thought I
didn't know Gina was going to toss it
back nothing gonna what go for the
onside no there's not enough time
hopefully you you've turned the ball
over to me twice right once no it I had
a pic fumble yeah so well this guy looks
good though most start most start looks
good in preseason he had a he had to run
back at they are no Bolden Bolden jr. or
golden junior one of them had to add a
run back Cameron says Tom Brady could do
it he could come back 21 they had to go
right the go could do this the goat the
goatee the goatee
alright so we need a miracle here
oh it's dick he's not dead he's not dead
yeah Brady Tom Brady to me oh my god we
try to run the safe play we just run a
power run to the right and we get we get
smashed for it like what what can you do
what can you do oh my god get it Oh
how's it damn it how is it it doesn't
count does it
how is it what do you get a few houses
you get a point one point yeah Oh God
Navaro the stud oh wait Oh what do you
get for that yeah point or two points
you go for two I get two baby let's go
man that just that actually just
potentially wanted us to seal the game
possession that's a two-possession game
I was trying to hit anger on slant I
don't know did you Oh woo that that was
a big play by Navarro whoa what was that
I don't know I'm on sidings recovering
though alright how do I do this that's
right Montana's resume is flawless
flawless I don't know how to do this how
do I use your catch really bad as I
think Sam has it
I think Vance McDonald saved me we good
Wow Wow pretty good onside kick that was
pretty good onside kick okay oh you know
what we can't we just can't he's gonna
run the ball around with are you gonna
run the ball are you gonna play okay
apparently look at what happened when I
ran the damn ball oh it's our lowest
rate gave it up Pharaoh says the knight
King is better armed than anyone in the
NFL that's good Game of Thrones
reference [ __ ] oh my god get off me oh
no not like my god Brian Hoyer please oh
my god not like this not like this not
like this where I just went for two and
I'd let you run it back oh my god no
give me a chance Nick not like I press
the wrong button
if anyone
chad is curious about what happened
there all right it's not gonna get it's
not gonna make a difference so I'm gonna
kick google right there to the wrong guy
legitimately we got a game now though oh
oh wow hey this is Kyle Shanahan Atlanta
part two part two what you gonna do oh
you're gonna play straight up okay so I
should be running the ball then right
God can see this is a lesson in not not
uh not running it there I what time is
it I actually don't think we do we have
enough time for another game should we
play another game cuz this is pretty
great
I'm worried right now though I'm 100%
worrying this how is he gonna blow this
that's a good question yes so it's Benny
McAdoo over there all right he's got two
timeouts he could win with a field goal
which is kind of annoying so you know oh
my god should've ran I feel you Tyler
Ross this is how you lose championships
this is how it lands yeah last time you
ran I forced the fumbles it's how
Atlanta did it though the chase all caps
run the ball alright you got it you got
it we're running the ball I need to
strip you that's funny do I need to
strip is there a way to like is there
like a power hold or whatever like with
the with the I think it's our one I
think we hold our one and disempower old
which means you can't sprint I don't
think in the same time please James
what's up I seen the chat you guys
defense scores more than your offense
that's right that's correct play one
more so Tyler Ross I feel I feel like
that should happen all right we have a
barbecue today you cut into my water
perform that the Heimlich I don't know
maybe man chat turned on you quit get
their chat turned on you pretty quickly
nah they just like watching a good game
they turn on me like they want to they
want to see a good game Nick what do you
expect chat bunch of savages you turn on
people
alright come on come on big stop here
timeout are you passing are you passing
occurs here big first big first are you
passing the ball oh my God he's passing
no get through it all I was supposed to
hit X now D give me the ball back and
let me blow up for myself or do you go
for he's gonna go for it he's gonna go
for it boys and girls
Kubb says i'll turn on you in a second
Nick just for your information I'm not
gonna look I'm not looking just so chat
knows I'm not looking at what he's doing
alright alright here chat this is for
the game chat what do i do what do i do
chat do i oh god I'm so scared
this is for the game chat is he running
the ball
Olivier Vernon should I do this I mean
no no when in doubt boys and girls you
go for the slant when the safety is not
up I made that mistake earlier we didn't
do it there just a quick simple West
Coast here we go game over
let's get to the next game Nick yeah
it's over how do i how do I just like
Neal it out damn how die Neal it out
I'll call time I'll just singing throats
give it a go Depot and go deep one just
for fun just for just for what have you
pick it and take it
I won't I won't do it I'll take it I
will run out of it I will run out of
busting what if you caused a fumble here
I will run out of Bounce you have my
word
coaching adjustments go deep gotta go
deep Hail Marys see coach's suggestion
is to kneeled yes obviously could all
come on coach's suggestions wait
we took enough chances we took enough
chances and we found a way to give him
to get him back into the game we're not
taking any more I don't want the
Heimlich it's over if you want to play
another game Nick I'll play you right
now straight up but we want two points
want to play the same teams and play the
same team
it back I'll run it back with you no no
no different teams we should we play as
the same team oh I don't care that's up
to you that's up to chat chat what do
you want to see same team or two
different teams I know who I'm picking
if it's a different team go ahead and
show me who you're gonna pick nada I'll
be victim agent you be home you that's
right war dog victory formation correct
I'm embarrassed but I also feel like I
redeemed myself slightly slightly if I'd
won I would have fully redeemed myself
but I didn't I didn't win so he season
tonight yeah well there is day night I
don't know who's playing tonight but I
said I'm just happy football's back I
know Giants for the Jets
what's a n team's hasn't beat Super Bowl
teams I can be the dirty pads Browns
same teams Nick still has the advantage
Oh
Eagles no way get out of here
the Finn the Bears who wants to see the
fence who wants to see the Bears nobody
wants to sort in three man says same
team I don't care
says DCP 77 dolphins versus Eagles or
Panthers vs check oh now you're just
trolling us same team says the West on
so now we're not doing same changing it
up fine I'm going I knew it going with
the Steelers I got I got a levy on I
gotta have eight B so should I be the
Steelers too or should I be the shy B
should I be could be Seahawks if you
want or I could be the Raiders one of
the Raiders run 86
how about Raiders oh we could do
tonight's preseason game what is
tonight's preseason right now
tonight's preseason game is Miami
Philadelphia nobody want to see that
Butler I'll be Cutler nobody wants to
see that Cutler I'll because make me
play an 83 that's horseshit
oh you know why Jay Ajayi still I hit
him the Eagles probably like a 78 yeah
78 that's fair
I'm just gonna play the uniform I'm
ready
oh sorry the dirty you're making me
plays the Dirty Birds choice four
minutes or three minutes three three
okay the Dirty Birds
oh crap dad pick simulation next Nick is
so salty
I don't know I think you did my bad Chad
you fool that's all you have to pick our
game you have to pick Arcade no well
yeah it's like simulation arcade
simulation I just went at the time
what's the difference
simulation is like real football the
clock runs oh that's good we don't have
that much time okay
no no no it's not an accelerated clock
arcade accelerates the clock this lets
the clock run like oh like normal yeah
double or nothing on teh mind games you
know goop I'll tell you what when I was
on the last stream with Jake I said to
you that if we got the top ten and Pub G
that I would owe you lunch double or
nothing
you owe me a nice fancy lunch or no
lunch at all wasn't this stadium Denis
needs to be it wasn't my fins up guys
Oh God ends up this is this dream this
is the best dream ever fins up it went
from being the worst dream to the best
dream
alright here we go here we go baby Miami
with the Cutler I draw I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna do no sports casting when I'm
gonna get paid to start oh my god this
is now oh look at how how much what a
shoddy kick that was wasn't this stadium
wasn't the landshark stadium playing
sharp logins Cutler was here an intro
for him or no no I just walked out I saw
his jersey
alright coupe says are you a chicken
dinner this is even out then okay no I'm
not losing alright he's feeling very
confident about this bet ends up fins to
the right hey Kevin probably to the left
final game after this unfortunately but
not once my Bronco is Raiders that would
have been a good game
you're already cutting into my barbecue
time chat come on why didn't you turn it
up for those of you who don't know today
is the CBS Interactive who owns GameSpot
barbecue company Barb's and it started
an hour ago
barbecue you know that right it's food
food truck whatever it's a barbecue also
it's terrible weather outside so know I
supposed to get better all right let's
see if Jay Cutler's got a got a throwing
arm here or maybe he's gonna run the
ball whoops where's my boy Jarvis set
Jarvis dolphin a team land truck same
hard rock baby baby obj right there Oh
PJs Devante Parker no drivers or Jarvis
land Jarvis Landry is so good get there
baby a giant come on Jarvis Jarvis
Landry fingers crossed I want him in
fancy if you have obj Jarvis Landry whoa
hey how do you drop that Nick how did
how did a giant I was on him I was on
him user tackle also cuz Cutler's is
garbage dude that's a great pass right
there Cutler is garbage he's a garbage
player God their trip sets are awful and
anyone who argues that cap so we're
gonna have this conversation oh we're
gonna have this cap converse that cap
should have have come to Miami
no Cutler already knew the offense it
was a smart play and forcing it to my
boy Julia Oh wouldn't I
murdered him P I also I'm gonna also say
that I'm gonna say this I said also 200
him wearing that t-shirt and then trying
to go down and play in Miami not a good
look not a good look I'm not saying that
he's a bad person but I am saying that
he's made some some dumb decisions off
the field that hurt him I don't I agree
with that I think that if he just played
his game he would be fine cap is
definitely in this game because I got
him as a card in Ultimate Team so he's
in this game
he's a silver card we go on four chat we
don't we don't give an F
Misato
yes let's go oh he was covered bad luck
she was covered yeah Thank You camp
Karen Greeson turns out he turns out
Scuttler it's not as good as my boy
Brian Hoyer apparently Jesus who would
ever say that you know I just saw I
think was on the ESPN Instagram or
something like that yesterday that they
released the coach's poll for the top
quarterbacks in the league and Cutler
was legitimately in like the top 15
which makes no sense to me how Cutler is
in the top 15
he's had solid you do realize though the
one silver lining here of him being in
Miami is that his offense oh yeah one of
his best years was underwater and can't
talk was under gaze yeah and dr. Suh Oh
Dan when I step on you bro and I step on
you with su whoa
I am going to disagree though with gravy
biscuits here nobody wants to meet these
circus I agree
Tebow same as Tebow I disagree I think
Tebow deserves to play saying that
there's a football baseball whatever
although honestly if he keeps playing
the way he's been playing in minors the
minors he's gonna have a career oh come
on my guys are slow on this deal I'm not
like the Niners i I think that Tebow I
think he's a decent below average
quarterback but I don't think that he's
a media circus I think that he plays the
game the way that the game suppose we
played whether that's baseball or that's
football and people just give him [ __ ]
for no reason I just don't
he's a good guy yes he's religious
whatever who cares being told I'm not
abusing camera and waking up I gots to
do that all right what am I doing here
Oh manis triple camera week oh good call
Cameron yeah I almost got pick off that
goop says Tebow talk he never mattered
never speak his name again
man he's killing in the minors he's yeah
he's doing all right in the minors
I'm not going for I'm kicking the field
goal we're playing smart this game what
up
I should have ran the ball a little bit
more hands up I love that I love that
Jimmy Buffett song we got time yeah we
got time to come back
we got time for him to make mistakes I'm
okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm Gucci man
this guy's got no leg I should've sprung
outside maybe I just alright my
formations are not working oh here's a
sick and a fell question for you who
know not who what conference is the best
in the league right now wait say that
guess what conference is the best I'm
going on that ich set no I think the
what's the what's the one where the
Raiders the Broncos and AFC West yes
that dad that one and Charteris yeah
it's the Chargers Chargers Raiders
broncos and cold is it now maybe it's
not Colts it's uh whichever one I'm
naming I think that one's the most like
stacked overall like in terms of just
the the quality of teams all across the
whole vision yeah cuz like the NFC East
is what Cowboys Redskins Giants and then
like one crappy team yeah it is yeah
well I mean I guess the Redskins are
gonna be that bad but oh yeah oh even
worse Broncos Raiders Chiefs Chargers
not worse in like I mean worse as in
like it was a stronger less bad
also division thanks goob what'd I say
division let's go Jay murdered so open
he was right about to run his in cut
murder even Lewis James says AFC West
yeah alright I agree
then what's all right then what's number
two what's its the second most difficult
conference in the NFL right now not
Conference Division sorry keep saying
conference conference is just a FC vs
NFC right AFC West though for sure that
that division just top to bottom like
they're always competing with each other
the Chiefs are the fourth team I don't
know about that Chiefs look look pretty
good and Erie baby
Papa Reed's been losing weight murdered
wow what is this like third and
twenty-two how is this 34th in 3d how
does this team rated higher than the
Niners they're so bad that's why I don't
want to play with them I got a pun yeah
I'm half that I can't I can't go on 4th
and 28th all right maybe I'm calling bad
plays there it could be my fault it's
usually the users fault we'll figure it
out chattering laughs as Giants Cowboys
are gonna be great this year
Eagles are on the rise Redskins I agree
who knows you never know with the
Redskins what's gonna happen is the
fourth team in that league division
though that's it it's Giants cowboys
Eagles skins ok that's a pretty good
that's comparable but the thing is with
that division I feel like every team for
some reason in that division ends up
being like eight and eight or nine and
seven like whenever they can never
string it together like the Giants that
one year they're like what six an O or
something and then all of a sudden like
they blow it blow it like I'll say it
reminds me heavily it reminds me heavily
of like the SEC football
we're like SEC teams are the best in the
nation in all they do all regular season
long in the NCAA is they beat up on each
other and then those teams have two
losses and they don't go to the playoffs
even though they're better than some of
these other teams that are in different
conferences that have better records
I wish the NC double-a committee would
take that into effect but it's like that
where it's like when it's a good
conference the teams are gonna play each
other two times they're gonna beat up on
each other and it's gonna hurt I don't
know what I picked damn that was dumb
come on lead lead the receiver
arts baby Zach Ertz isn't Earth's
injured I'm not sure who uh chat there's
somebody on the Eagles that just got
injured is it
Earth's I think it is I'm sure ants were
eleven or five were they really eleven
yeah they were they went to the playoffs
and we got smoked smoked by the Packers
yes Thank You Cameron Leslie seeing ACC
teams are better than 95% of the college
football that's why when TCU complains
that they're not you know all we need to
be in in the converse and we're getting
double conversation Oh Jordan Matthews
is hurt and he weren't even on this team
he's not on the friends who his drug
loves trees I got bills though since
when since they traded Watkins they are
the walkins and then they traded um
Matthews to Buffalo what was this this
was like a week ago
wow I use it's not on that team I was
not falling also I'm not paying should
have never caught that ball to begin
with
alright 48 seconds left watch play my
running can you guess okay right now
focus on getting off the line here
Oh God nice catch Wow Wow update those
rosters baby this game manon mathews got
her first day of bills practice that's
also he was already gone he was already
he was gone and then he got like a rib
injury or something oh I'm not sure
chattering last discussion with somebody
about Eagles lost somebody big and I was
like who was it so he wasn't even on the
team uh what am I doing here what am I
doing here
come on Cameron one time we gotta get
home update these rosters Cameron oh no
time to get the ball off man I need a
touchdown here
there's a lot of there's no there's been
some Rosser ruse what about that Kyrie
though
Kyrie trade what a joke got him oh my
lord
I'll Sean Jeffrey he dropped that he
dropped opted yes that gone for you
plain smart
Oh God Oh God think it we still in here
guys we still in here Anquan Boldin did
retire we're still in the game
we got three timeouts maybe the fin
looks good
maybe Cutler can get us a little bit of
a field goal opportunity I doubt it how
do you miss that I highly doubt it
how do you miss that that wasn't even
win that was me I let that thing swing
too much trying it again oh god oh god
sorry chat I panicked I panicked
Nick margarita switch to wait what the
pad yeah my bad chat I panicked I'm just
trying to get a field goal here 42 yards
are you gonna kick up no no I got 10
seconds man I can run a quick play I got
another timeout Tim how I would that go
deep
oh-ho that is a savage thing to say
LeBron is going to LA next year anyway
so he said as well some people have
speculated that for a while they could
even get a Paul George if they want Bron
Bron what I hate the NBA right now I'll
say right now I am NOT in a nation I'm
not an NBA fan dubnation sure my Knicks
suck but like dubnation on them
oh you got bumped dude I got pee ID I'll
see cool on see you call can I can I get
a replay no you can't can we at least
watch it you don't you don't get it you
either go for the field goal here you
don't let's see what's a 62-yard 59-yard
where's the flag get out here no flags
dude did you see that
my guy straight-up got like you got
contacted like 10 yards down the field
man 10 yards down the field he got
contact did you see him get bumped
that's why he stopped his route when
it's all I hear throw it early run out
of bounds get this field goal what
second you kidding me how you do it boys
and girls
yeah show them that first down to fasano
Oh is there a second left on this clock
how long is this one
45 45 that's realistic who's your kicker
Sturgis Kaleb Sturgis guy strong like
well it's Franks who the hell is Frank
oh god this is so jittery
alright harder the further back you are
that's pretty close that's pretty close
tie game [ __ ]
oh no good the short short what yeah
sure max power that kickers bad dude
that kickers no games why what happen to
Kaleb Sturgis no bueno all right second
half and then it's barbecue time what is
this game right now
what are we just witness let's see
that's pretty much of max powered that
[ __ ] from 45 yards all right come on get
off me
that was not five yards Cory Kirk he got
bumped like ten yards down the field I
can't even I can't even feel confident
right now cannot believe he just missed
that field goal Oh
how does he miss that viewable max power
forty-five yards
it's not even a 50-yard I got him in
position there's no way that guy would
ever make a 59 yarder then that was a
little scary
Shawn the first time what's his first
name
Ultron Frank's made two 50-yard kicks
last season in the same game and he
can't make a 45 yard in term and that's
what I that is what I'm saying Cameron
was here
you saw that I hit at least 90 plus
percent power it was definitely up there
I don't know if I got the red but I
definitely got I got that blue okay I'm
going for the fences I don't care
I should square up though I should squat
and say there's no further downfield
Blount came over from the Pats right
yeah you like that now he's a lead back
because they cut Ryan Matthews who's uh
who's Pat's RB now they've got a bunch
they still got um oh ah let's see they
got oh why am i blanking ridley no not
release not Vereen either
oh god whose deal Lewis Oh Jung Lewis
and they have someone else to do that I
can't remember
alright deal at the moment they're fine
at running back
believe me the entire Patriots team yeah
yeah I read the same thing about oh
goody I heard the same thing about
Blount
Oh solace Lee oh yeah thank you che
gravy biscuits shattering last yeah I
forgot about that I've seen butterflies
with better open field tackling come on
say yeah I know I was just throwing
bodies at him trying to scare him
hopefully
hoping he would just have a random
phantom
fumble here oh my gosh what a catch
oh damn it's fourth down though right
yeah we gonna do here where am i 31 and
we gonna do here I'll go for it
wow he's going for it guys Oakland
Raiders savage man Madden looks good
yeah it does
oh they also have Rex Burkhead and James
White they've got a plethora of just
gooses started probably James boy
catching receiving type of bat wasn't
James why starting for them and he was
splitting carries with one of them was
hurt Dion Lewis was hurt until like
midseason that was weird you see that he
was showing the kicking team warming up
and then once came out yes drop it we
just don't get any pressure with this
team
you were you were pressuring you were
pressuring Eli on every snap in the last
game every snap he was under duress
this is tonight's preseason game yeah
I'm gonna watch it why don't you want to
watch that Malik I want it I want to see
you al Sean I want to see he was looked
pretty decent in pre-season just
wondering if he's still a always wide
open I said the house that's play wide
open how bad is this that I might
potentially not saying I will I might
potentially win with a division run and
I lost with my Giants yeah that hurts no
good RP for fantasy for new yeah
absolutely not he'll split carries the
whole time I think the young mr. James
White is is okay but like yeah I
wouldn't bank on it it's just like
Reggie had last year even Seattle's
tough because it's like yeah Eddie
Lacy's gonna start but you're probably
gonna have to pick up Thomas Rawls too
just in case
and Eddie Lacy has an attitude problem
you're not a new team still isn't super
oh here we go chat we got four minutes
oh uh find a way to uh oh that is the
worst kicks what yeah where's kick his
most powerful kick maybe you have the
win to buy the win to my back
Oh God I want to see Cutler through a
90-yard dart with a lit cigarette in his
mouth you remember what is does anyone
remember in the chat what his logo for
blitz was against the Packers no it was
Aaron Rodgers his was uh it was this
that was the call for like blitz all
right what are we doing here I have a
funny feeling today he's gonna be going
down the field often I don't know
whether to play zone though that was
Sturgis Sturgis
who's that was he talking about Sturgis
Oh God
come on see he's out he's out he's out
thank you
Cutler yeah
googling smoke and Jay Cutler great
images Sturgis on the Eagles now he's
gone quiet I think he's a little nervous
gunned it I just hate Jay Cutler it
turns out no one likes Jay Cutler Jay
Cutler doesn't even like Jay Cutler I
literally aggressive
Devante Parker let's go XX bill says are
y'all doing gauntlet we did a little bit
of gauntlet earlier in the stream sir if
you're on YouTube you can kind of scrub
back but when this is on demand on
Twitch you'll be able to scrub back we
only played once through each and we
tied actually you just strip all right
he's moving now everyone saying bring it
home Tay
where's my support come on
that was late those late we got we got
away with that one because Cutler's just
not a good not a good look right now all
right
ooh ooh you a lot of support here the
fade oh come on
Jarvis you gotta win that one-on-one
attention on the one I really don't I
picked that I really thought I'd pick
that that was a sketchy past yeah I
agree if Nick wins we'll need a
tiebreaker
yeah the tiebreaker will be Matt into 19
next year come on chat rip Tannehill
yeah oh yeah does he never got surgery
from his knee injury last year gyrus
would have won that yeah I agree
Jarvis definitely wouldn't want that I
don't want to what play I just called
but going to my slant this land was
there still life still live the slant
was a hundred percent there you gotta go
for it here no I don't i 100% don't have
to go for it I got to tie this game up
okay all right are you kidding me dude
gravy biscuits I miss NCAA football to
the Vontae Parker how do you how you
miss that also guys don't forget hit
that like and that subscribe button cuz
we're on a killer stream number one and
number two because you'll be notified Oh
God
oh no you'll be notified when we go live
is uh we've been pretty much streaming
here on GameSpot every day 11 a.m.
Pacific right correct so hit that
subscribe to Morrow actually a little
bit early we're gonna be here tomorrow
10:00 a.m. for call of duty kavita god
beta if you're a Comcast customer get on
that betta bro this how do we do this
you just want to hit it lightly
I mean it's Riddler it's a trap as a
crapshoot oh let's go
are you let's go sorry for the yelling
rip headphone users are you kidding me
uh sin the sin II says hang on what cut
is on the Vita know the bida bida like
the beta are you bring out those pins
boys oh god what oh that was nice by you
you said that tackle and took it away
what is I had the whole I had the whole
there the soldier says on sidekick
mechanics and Madden though how did I
get that burst
you gotta get that burst up there and
why is the Giants fan playing the Eagles
because chat that's why cuz chat said
I'm sad too let's OH
Johan Tate your offense is literally
butterfingers Devante are you not gonna
catch that slam Devante Parker I had on
my fantasy team
he was dog s we drew we got our it
savant a man now I got a third and 10
when we should have got like five yards
in the first run and that's lamb the
Giants are bad get out of here the jaw I
will predict this right now Giants will
beat the Eagles both both times we play
you guys a season oh my god user what my
skill let's go Devante way to make up
for it you took away my slant to Jarvis
but uh Parker came across we had bevel
slants going there a double slants
alright what are you doing here
don't tie this game here Oh slam Oh got
a stripper try to do a little right
stick a little right stick action there
Cameron says I'm hoping for overtime
stream is already an hour too long
I thought he had I was one move away I
should spot on him
she gave him that spinner ooh we were
one-on-one Jay Ajayi
against the safety we couldn't couldn't
give him that little burst that we
needed to well little stutter will shake
him bake it oh wow all right we'll call
timeout here we'll call timeout no no no
for Russia's with a je disgraceful
why do de ja he was like you're like the
only thing the scenes or the the
dolphins had going for them he really
was like the only saving grace on that
team go Landry hey we don't tie games
here we go for the W we going for -
[Music]
we're going for the W guys we're going
for the W we don't do we don't go for
ties here we're going for it we go for
the W Cameron we're going for the
cormorant the the victory here
do we call the play you know what hold
on time time out guys I don't think I
called the play that I wanted to so
let's make sure we got our play let's
make sure we get our play here all right
let's make sure let's make sure what you
can tie in football McNabb yes - I'm not
gonna look I don't want to see his
defensive coverage Oh gravy viscous
wants to say PA I know I know but we
gotta go here we gotta go we got we have
to yes yes yes yes
I just blew up my line he blew it up
what can I do you onside it yeah I'm on
siding what can I do chat what can I do
ya [ __ ] that's a bad kick Oh who just
got it whoo you got it he did he did
botch it up for a second there though
yes I think I should it through I think
I should have threw the fade that is
true Liz I am distracted I got barbecue
on my mind but that is no excuse I'm
gonna win this one yes I need my I need
my team to straight-up just go goal-line
here blow up everything I don't even
care we're playing like like and we
wasted a timeout - on that one play so
we're pretty much done we're cooked here
I'm pretty much cooked feels bad man dad
I couldn't the slant wasn't there yet so
I couldn't throw it so by the time he
got to us fumble fumble it look Garrett
I'm going long I'm gonna go deep I'm
gonna go deep I'm gonna go deep and feel
free to run it back here we go better
get it off you got five seconds
I'll call time really quick gonna go
deep to end the stream yes I'm gonna get
the V gonna get the victory the W let's
go you're just finally I've won a game
honestly and you win last time no I lost
every game we play really I lost every
game we play I roll back the tape
somebody look up this dream well please
God don't look up the stream from Madden
17 last year all right here we go I only
have one guy back there oh hi I'm sorry
Cameron I tried as much as I want to go
for the W as much as I would say we'd
have a grudge match I'm craving some
fight I had to go for the W chat we
weren't about to go into ot I know a
smart man would I went to ot I play flag
football myself I would have went to ot
but hey thank you guys all for tuning
and that was Madden NFL 18 we opened
some packs we got like two elites out of
four packs played a little gauntlet they
little gone with that was fun I enjoy
those tied you up there and we went one
for one there but all I know is that the
Niners took out the Giants so that's
good enough for me Jay Cutler is still
bad in my opinion I hope you guys have a
good rest of the day tomorrow we'll be
here back 10 a.m. GameSpot live for some
Call of Duty beta I hope you guys are
there I hope you guys have some and fall
if you haven't you should do that do it
get on that see y'all later
our friends PCO
[Music]
so that'll do it for us for my partner
Charles Davis and all the hard-working
men and women on our crew